good afternoon everyone I am Christina
Talbert slagel assistant professor at
the Yale School of Medicine and director
of The Faculty support initiative at the
Yale Institute for Global health I am
also the principal investigator for
applying research for a healthy Liberia
a five-year collaborative project with
the University of Liberia College of
Health Sciences and Van built University
funded by the US agency for
International Development I am delighted
to welcome you to This Global Health
conversation series event Ebola 10 years
on Reflections and Lessons Learned in
addition to the Yale Institute for
Global health or Y today's event is
co-sponsored by the Walker fund and the
Council on African studies at the M
McMillan Center at
Yale this December marks the 10-year
anniversary of the emergence of Ebola in
the West African country of Guinea an
event that caused a tragic epidemic and
more than 10,000 deaths in Guinea and
its neighboring countries Liberia and
Sierra Leon since the 2013 to5 Ebola
epidemic the world has experienced
numerous Global Health threats such as
further Ebola outbreaks marberg measles
and covid-19 among
others during this webinar three senior
health leaders who responded to the
Ebola epidemic in Liberia Guinea and
Sierra Leon will share their Reflections
on the weaknesses in health care public
health and health financing that
exacerbated the Abol crisis in their
countries as well as lessons learned
that can be or have already been applied
to respond better to emerging infectious
disease threats build more more
resilient Health Systems and improve
health outcomes globally it is our
pleasure to have three distinguished
guests joining us today all of whom are
esteemed leaders in global Public Health
to formally introduce our panelists I
will now turn to my colleague Dr Sabine
Franklin hello everyone my name is Dr
Sabine Franklin and I am a melon
post-doctoral fellow in the Africana
studies department at Welsley College
col it is my pleasure to introduce our
distinguished panel and to moderate
today's
event Dr Bernice Dawn was the minister
of health of Liberia from 2015 to 2018
and previously served as the chief
medical officer of Liberia from 2006 to
2015 where she oversaw postwar Health
System strengthening e efforts she is
currently the vice president for Health
Sciences at the University of Liberia
leading the College of Sciences which
houses the only schools of Medicine and
Pharmacy in the country as well as the
new School of Public Health and nursing
Midwifery
program Dr Don has authored more than 40
Publications spearheaded an investment
plan for building a resilient health
system in Liberia postola and is
internationally recognized expert in
health system strengthening and pandemic
recovery Dr caam is a public health
specialist with more than 20 years
experience in Health Management and
Leadership across Africa he is currently
an independent consultant and a
part-time research associate at the
University of the in Sagal he has been
with amrath health Africa the largest
healthc care nonprofit on the continent
from 2011 until 2018 when he was the
regional director of am in West Africa
prior to that he worked with the
Ministry of Health in Sagal in various
positions at district and National
levels leading various campaigns notably
to reduction of the malaria cases via
systemic changes to the ministry's
surveillance and delivery of
services Paramount Chief David Mandu
Farley Kylie kumber the four is an
experienced engineer who spent two
decades in the United States before
returning to Sierra Leon in 2008 to work
in the mining sector he was elected to
head the Mandu chiefdom in the kyen
Hound District on December 2nd
2013 a few weeks later the first case of
the Ebola virus disease in a child
occurred in the guco do prefecture in
Guinea which borders the kyah Hound
district and It ultimately caused the
child's death
and Trigger the 2013 to 2016
pandemic thus one of his first
governance challenge was to implement
emergency bylaws he convinced other
Paramount Chiefs in the kyah Hound
District to implement the same bylaws to
discourage movement close contact and
encourage health-seeking
behaviors these were later scaled up and
implemented as part of Sierra Leon's
National Emergency declaration in August
2014 te so welcome to all of our
panelists it is great to have you here
with us
today so we are moving now to the first
round and I asked each panelist this
question it has been 10 years and tens
of thousands of Articles photos and
reports on the deadliest outbreak of the
Ebola virus disease what part of the
narrative or the story is missing and
can you tell us that story story in two
minutes I will start with Dr
Don thank you
and hello to everyone who is on to
listen
um the so um it's 10 years after the
outbreak and uh during the
outbreak there was this momentum to
build resilient Healthcare Delivery
Systems to ensure that the impact of
outbreaks will not be felt like the way
it was felt during the Ebola outbreak
for
countries and countries should be better
prepared
for new
emergencies which part of the story that
is not is not being
told there was
um momentum to support
countries strengthen
countries in along uh building the
resilient Healthcare Delivery
Systems countries
supported um countries that were weak to
help them build the resilient Healthcare
Delivery Systems promises were
made some of those premises were not
fulfilled not every promise that was
made was a new
promise and moving
onwards uh whether countries still align
to the efforts of building a resilience
that we all felt should have been
built with with the outbreak of the dis
of Ebola and moving
on so for me I will summarize that to
that and wait for the next question
thank
you thank you Dr Don uh so move on to Dr
theam uh could you please tell us what
parts of the story or the narrative is
missing in two
minutes
okay
Pro
ver person
that's
see um Paramount Chief Farley uh could
you tell us what part of the narratives
or the story is missing and could you
please tell us that in two
minutes two issues uh there are many but
uh two principal issues one is how
important uh the governance structure
governance issues
are uh to properly
address uh uh emerging diseases and
specifically uh a problem like Ebola uh
I can give examples of that later on um
that's the first issue the second issue
is
that um in terms of local
populations uh Ebola was um a very
severe
crisis um but uh keeping it in
perspective uh there are
still normal diseases that are endemic
here that probably that kill so many
more people
uh long after uh the international
efforts have been uh very well
appreciated International efforts we are
made to combat Ebola I'm talking
specifically about malaria and typhoid
which continues
unfortunately uh to take a very high
mortality toll on our regular
populations um and so while we're very
happy about uh the attention that was
brought uh or to uh uh our Healthcare
issues uh by Ebola by Eola epidemic
there's an ongoing um endemic of regular
diseases that need to be addressed uh
and that the population will want people
like me to keep talking
about all thank you Chief Paramount
Chief Farley um and so we'll bring it
back to Dr Don what was the most
significant challenge you fa during the
Ebola crisis in your country and how did
you
respond uh
initially
coordinating donor
Partners to align to and respond to the
emergency was
challenging
we had an emergency and everyone was
willing to help so we had a lot of
influx of Partners both donors and
implementing partners coming in to
help we were having coordination
meetings but uh from the initial stages
those Co coordination meetings were not
very
efficient and so Partners
were like parachuting boing and doing
things on their
own until we were able to to
regroup uh designed a system that
brought in the incident management
system established emergency operation
centers map out the partners and divided
them
geographically to support specific
things within the
counties and help to build a County
Health capacity before we were able to
get it
Street okay thank you Dr Don um and Dr
theam what was the most significant
challenge you faced during the Ebola
crisis um when you were in Guinea and
how did you
respond the
mity
for
dir
thank you Dr tham um and Paramount Chief
Farley what would you say um was the
most significant challenge that you
faced ONN Ebola and Sierra
Leon okay there are several issues but I
think they all center around the fact
that Ebola uh was the first really major
Modern Health crisis uh that the country
had
experienced uh and so uh the first thing
was the very negative reaction of our
local communities we were a little bit
fortunate that it started in the rural
areas uh and by the time it had gotten
to the urban areas
um the the situation was still bad but
um at least the government had had some
experience with what was happening but
the major issue there was a stigma uh
associated with the um with the disease
um when a community suddenly starts
seeing uh their several members of their
of their Community going to hospital and
ding
consistently um and when they saw
ambulances coming into Community they
they will usually uh the youth will
gather up and and throw stones at the at
the at the ambulances and and maybe and
not even accept uh those Health
initiatives uh also because of stigma
associated with the uh
disease uh and high fatality uh that was
involved in the in the in the disease
because of a very poor health care
System uh when you had Ebola it was
basically a sentence of death uh and so
people used to hide the fact that they
had Ebola at all uh and that obviously
helped in its transmission there was
also the issue of
um
people wanting a TR a cultural um
dictates that uh we have a very caring
Community uh usually people uh usually
visit sick people uh and and especially
when somebody dies uh a large number of
people in communities usually attend to
that that person that person and
obviously in the case of Ebola um people
who cont got got in contact with
somebody who who even died from Ebola or
got sick from Ebola uh will easily get
the disease so it became an almost
almost a hopeless situation where uh if
they say you have Ebola or if somebody
got sick he will hide the fact that he
was sick even if he was just he or she
was just sick with malaria or typhoid or
some really
perfectly curable disease uh they will
deny that they have that disease because
uh once they they were told the
authorities knew that they had Ebola uh
they'll be taken to an ebola Center
where they'll invariably never return uh
it got a little bit better uh as time
went on um when we had better facilities
sorry Paramount chiefy have to interrupt
you got 10 seconds left
okay it got a little bit better but but
that that was the main issue that we had
to deal with then of course we had to
deal with the the poor uh governance
structure that we have but I'll address
that later on okay thank you Paramount
Chief Farley so we're moving on to the
next round where each panelist will have
one minute to respond so if a panelist
is responding and another panelist likes
the points that they made they can raise
two fingers such as I'm demonstrating
and they can add on to that person's
point for 20 seconds or if you can raise
a full hand to object if you want to
give a dissenting view you'll have 30
seconds to give that view and then the
original panelist will have 30 seconds
to respond to that view and yes I am
timing it on my timer so we will begin
with Dr Don um you also have the unique
experience of working inside a Ministry
of Health and what do you feel were the
challenges of of integrating those NGO
resources in a government response and
how can that be
improved is the question related to the
Ebola or just the
overall um it's related to Ebola for now
okay okay so yes thank you
um the
normally uh Partners both those donor
partners and implementing Partners will
stress
accountability
efficiency and
accountability uh working with the
government um you'll realize
that accountability is a one way
street okay so I was saying
um normally within GL Health people we
all stress
accountability and efficiency
Effectiveness and
efficiency uh when you work in the
government you realize that
accountability is a oneway
street donor Partners tend to hold
governments accountable for resources
that are provided for them from their
countries uh but they don't not but they
country the
recipient does not have the
same opportunity to ask for
accountability in the in the in the
other
direction so you will realize that for
example a donor gives an
NGO maybe 10 million could you wrap up
the example in just 10 seconds please
okay a donor gives an NGO million to
support uh Services you ask for detailed
Services a detail breakdown of that
budget is is it is difficult to get and
so it becomes difficult to align those
uh that resource to resources that you
already have to be able to complement
one another thank you thank you Dr Don
um and for Paramount Chief Farley can
you please tell us about the inter
interactions between emergency
responders and the local communities um
you know such as the burial teams
healthcare workers that you had
mentioned
earlier it started out really bad um as
I
said the first time I actually made it
that uh there was a a problem uh with
with the um in the country or at least
in our region was we just come back
from and I was I was traveling to a that
Wasing to my to my
own at night uh and I Farley we're
having a trouble hearing you if you
could speak a little louder please we're
having a little trouble hearing you
thank you all right um and I said I said
the first time I heard I I noticed that
we had a problem in the country was uh
when I when we were traveling from uh a
chief meeting of Paramount Chiefs in
Kyan district and uh at night and I saw
a huge crowd on the road roadside uh
attacking an
ambulance um and I had to come down and
I asked what was going on I found out
that uh they said the ambulance people
had said uh they had they had a um they
had brought in a corpse uh with a who
died from a new disease disas and that
there were on instructions not to let
them let the people handle that corpse
uh and so there was a huge Hue and cry
about that um and but that was the start
U but then unfortunately or maybe I
don't know uh
providentially uh in that same Chief
Dome not very long after that the wife
of the Paramount Chief died uh and
so there was a big much better thrust uh
of of
wanting to handle this this issue
together so that by the end of the uh
theep epidemic there was a very very
good uh relationship between the
community uh the medical care providers
uh and um the the the the the
traditional leaders like like us so it
started out very badly but over a period
of time uh we we ended up with the with
a fairly good relationship and it's a
good lesson that will learn for future
interventions all right thank you um Dr
Dawn can we go back for you to finish
your thought please in terms
of so what were the oh I'm sorry so the
original question were what were the
challenges of integrating those NGO
resources into the government response
and how these can be improved so you
left off at
accountability yes
so I was saying it is difficult to
especially for implementing Partners to
share detailed
budgets and so
um aligning those budget
to what you already have resources that
you have to ensure that they complement
one another is difficult take for
example quite
recently uh there was an RFA we decided
to join
with an NGO partner to
apply the
RFA one of the terms is to strengthen
local Health Systems and so local in
that
RFA 50% of the budget should go to local
institutions the international partner
was the one priming we agreed to
that uh
they brought down the budget and gave us
about uh 5.4 out of $24
million for over five years we did a
detailed budget for our portion of the
25 of the $24 billion which is the 5.4
but we just couldn't get them to give us
the details and we were Partners on the
table designing a
project and that is even
it's not the only one but it's it's been
happening uh I've noticed a difference
with training institutions and also the
health
sector most us universities for example
will tell you our overhead is 25%
35% so you know that and when you are
designing a project you take that into
consideration but all the US NOS will
not tell you what their overhead is
is not negotiated with the
government it's outside of it so you
really don't know what their overhead is
and then at the end of the day you
realize that what actually goes to the
project is by far less than what it is
and that has implications for government
because when uh they you sign a 50
million project for example in Liberia
liberians want to see $50 billion worth
of project Implement in terms of
implementation and so when they don't
see that they feel that the money has
been government is abusing the money and
things like that but many times those
monies don't even come to the country a
good portion of it don't even come to
the country and you you really don't see
how
much to really say this is the amount
that actually went program and services
and this went into overhead for others
and that I've seen the difference also
with some of the US training
institutions that they will be
transparent and we will all work the
budget together as to the NGO partners
that you really don't know how it goes
thank
you thank you Dr Don I see Paramount
Chief Farley has two fingers up so
please add on you have 20 seconds yes I
I'll just add that U there's an
accountability issue also on the part of
our national governments um I I govern a
local government a traditional local
government uh that used to exist even
before uh the colonial era uh and our
people implicitly trust their Paramount
Chief significantly much more so than
central government but even when we get
donations to our Central governments
very little of it triggers into into uh
our local communities into Chiefs like
like we have for instance and so uh it's
a double wary uh Dr Dan has a problem
with accountability from NOS we have a
problem but ngos still give a little bit
to the central government but even that
little bit the central government they
give central government does not get to
the communities which actually get to
implement things that actually address
the the the the diseases problems we
have in our communities so I just wanted
to butress
that thank you Paramount
Farley um and to follow up finally with
the Dr theam so you also have the unique
experience of working inside a Ministry
of Health and then working for a major
health NGO AMR so what do you feel are
the challenges of integrating NGO
resources um in this type of government
coordinated response how can that be
[Music]
improved the
problem the problem
PR
for
[Music]
thank you Dr H um and thinking now going
back to the very beginning of the Ebola
epidemic and the misconceptions around
it um such as stigma um local culture of
Customs or the involvement of local
communities in some regions um as a
result distrust developed between those
communities and those seeking to control
the epidemic so after working in these
different regions and your position as
Regional director of amref what have you
learned and how can we prevent mistrust
between communities and public health
responders
for
C
[Music]
El
Le
thank you Dr sh um and chief permount
chief Farley thinking about the
international responses for example msf
for Western governments that are often
put in the spotlight when dealing with a
global Health crisis such as
Ebola how is your work with other
Paramount Chief demonstrate that local
communities are capable of meeting these
challenges so how can we International
organizations or other governments
better support local communities to
address future
emergencies uh deal with paraman Chiefs
directly uh most of our community have
traditional governance structures that
the communities trust a whole lot more
than the national government uh most of
our national governments are
essentially uh inheritors of a mantle of
of the colonial
authorities uh and unfortunately in a
lot of African
countries um the in especially in the
rural areas or in the vast majority of
of the country uh the people in
governance in our major at the national
level U basically uh take take uh an
attitude of of a colonialist uh towards
the the rural areas and so like Inon
things get things are very highly
centralized uh most of our traditional
structures have have been weakened
significantly um and uh since our
productive capacity has been reduced Al
significantly uh to a large extent we
depend to a large extent on on funds
coming in from outside now uh a lot of
these funds go directly to the
government uh but a lot of it also goes
to NOS none of it goes to to Paran
Chiefs and and local leaders directly
and yet uh we are the people that people
trust uh more than anybody else to
deliver uh um the the caring the the
care that that they need uh so my my
suggestion uh one thing that we could
one way we could think about it is
obviously uh make get our NGS very
accountable but also have them uh give
them
instructions uh and find a way for to
monitor whether they have had Direct
relationships with traditional leaders
of those communities um and and there
are all sorts of uh uh things that ways
that they could we could structure that
but on a large large on on a broad basis
I think that that probably is the best
way to go uh
International countries or
organizations and NOS uh when they come
yes you need some permission from the
government to operate but make sure that
most of your resources are directed
towards interactions direct interactions
with your traditional leaders whom the
communities respond respond to a lot
better and who are a lot more
accountable to the
communities thank you Paramount Chief
Farley um and Dr Don we want to wrap up
this section um can you please tell us
about the lessons learned from Liberia's
experience with ebola and how that could
have been informed uh for this current
or recent outbreak with
covid thank you uh the systems we put in
place for the Ebola
outbreak help us with the covid
outbreak
the it was during the Ebola time that we
established the
emergency the
IMs emergency management system the
incident management system and then
establish the uh eoc's in the 15
counties Emergency Operations
centers
we also put in place a full surveillance
system from Community Based event
reporting to C real disease surveillance
active surveillance system within the
communities all the way to the central
level that is reported within 2448
hours so those systems the IMs is
normally activated when there is an
outbreak and then after the
outed the eoc's continue to function
within the counties because we will
always have some outbreaks that we can
manage normally misual outbreak for
example yellow fever those things
continue so the EOC continue to
function at the county level so with
with the outbreak of the covid the
emergency the IMs was reactivated
quickly all the eocs were they
functional and so you were able to
intervene
quickly now we also had a few challenges
with that
also the central level which is the IMs
system we
established during the after the Ebola
we established the national public
health in Institute and The Institute is
to is responsible for disease
surveillance and emergency
response the definition of that
emergency response because we know that
at some point the rooting Health
Services had to come in place especially
for case
management within the emergency
system so there was this struggle
between the central Ministry and the
National Public Health Institute ude as
to who provides the leadership for the
covid
response but fortunately for us at the
decentralized level the
eoc's were functional so they were able
to intervene quickly and then uh who
actually supported those of us who were
in country and had the experience of
managing the emergency to work at a
decentralized level some of us
especially where we had the outbreaks to
be able to Cil the disease so the system
actually helped us and then the impact
was not as much as we saw in other
countries okay thank you Dr Don um so we
want to move to this last round before
we open it up for Q&A um to give the
panelists a chance to respond to the
same question so each panelist again
will have 60 seconds to respond you can
raise two fingers to agree and add on
for 20 seconds or full hand to descent
and then add on for 30 seconds and then
the original panel member um we'll have
30 seconds to respond so how can
universal access to Primary Care Health
Care in lowincome countries improve
Global Health security what do donors
and Western based agencies need to
hear we'll start with Dr
tham
Dr oh okay not me right no
Dr
okay
for
[Music]
all right thank you Dr s uh Paramount
Chief
Farley thank you um first of all we have
to realize that uh we live in a much
smaller world now than than in the past
um
a disease some diseases aren't quite as
infectious as others um but uh they are
nevertheless endemic uh to the local
communities uh but if a community is um
has is used to um having very poor
health care uh to even take care of uh
malaria and typhoid and things like that
which have which which a lot of people
still die of um not because they they uh
they don't know what the diseases is uh
but it's it gets to a point where they
have to choose between buying food to
eat uh or um buying medicine and
invariably they'll they'll buy food or
keep buying food until the disease gets
so chronic that uh it it becomes
incurable now if you have a community
that that has uh that is inur to to
something like that when you actually
have something that that can be
transmitted that becomes a threat to
Western Nations like Ebola people don't
take it very seriously because they
already die every day uh and so they
have a very low expectation of healthare
delivery uh and therefore they are not
very responsive uh to to diseases that
that that um that the West will take a
lot a lot more uh I'll give you an
example like in the covid in the case of
covid I'll tell you that uh I don't know
by what Miracle covid uh um wasn't quite
as infectious uh around here as it was
in the west but if it were it l killed a
whole lot more people than Ebola uh but
but it's it's the same phenomenon that
people have have been used to having
very low expectation of healthare
delivery system and so so uh they when
infectious diseases that come that
affects that could affect uh the West
because of the travel you the the the
the ease of travel around the world that
becomes the threat so we all have an
interest uh in improving that primary
healthare within our our communities and
my final point is whatever you do start
start at the local governance level a
lot of it at National level never trick
trickles down there um but I I I I think
I'll talk about it more down the
line thank you Paramount Chief Farley Dr
Don okay thank you I will start by
saying weak systems will continue to
remain weak if they are not the systems
are not invested
in the first place is the government
often we all look up to the
government to invest in Building
Systems now when you look at the
government's budget if you take liia for
example that is a
resource a low income country and
resources are challenging you will
realize
that about 70 to
80% of the
budget allocated to the health sector
actually goes towards payment of of
salaries to
Personnel now the salaries also have
challenges there are salaries that
cannot meet the needs of the people who
are doing the work so that's the first
thing then you are left with 20 to
30% of the amount to build all the
systems that need to be in
place especially at the decentralized
level where
the actual services are being
delivered that tells you
that they to do that it will be
difficult now many times we have
Partners who are willing to invest in
helping but they also tend to look at
before the invest and gave the
government the
funding to to implement they will
complain about the weak
system then they prefer to give the
money to
NOS to implement and so the government
system is never
built now NGS will
Implement and when the funding is
finished
withdraw when they withdraw the the work
is left back for the government to take
on and the system is not there to take
it on
so they it's a virtual cycle now within
the NGO Community too there are
international communities International
Nos and there are local
NOS normally the international NOS are
stronger than the local
NOS so most of the time the funding also
goes to the international
Nos and then when they have the funding
they recruit from within the system
often the government system to do the
work so and then they pay better so then
the government system is being depleted
further so the system is never really
built for the government to be able to
take charge of the
system now government too has its own
problems we have had an opportunity to
move from one government to another
government and and you will realize that
some Partners have helped to build some
systems if you take the financial
management system for
example uh for Liberia the health uh the
unit Ministry of
Health uh during the previous
administration we had donor partners
that help us to put in systems for
financial management
procurement and the internal audit and
the rest of
it those system
function to a good
extent when you change
government and another government comes
in then the other government instead of
looking at the system the new government
looking at the system that existed and
built on it they start to do something
else new all together and so what was
started before never get to continue and
then the the system Contin to be weak so
it's both ways and that need to be
looked into carefully the governments
themselves maybe they don't I don't know
whether they understand building a
regular system is more political
driven than actual technical work and so
we continue to have this vicious cycle
of being growing small and and taking
like three steps in front and 10 steps
backwards once you change government and
so there's a need to also really look at
that the government systems need to be
built properly government and uh
Partners work together to build a system
so that it will be sustainable thank
you thank you Dr Don and I see two
fingers first from Paramount Chief
Farley and then Dr tham Chief Farley yes
just a quick point to BCE what Dr Dan is
said um and and a solution to what the
problem that uh of changing the the
whole system at National level whenever
you have a change of government because
most of these political leaders at
National level um use we don't have uh a
merit system that exists like in the US
um when you have a change of governments
all all of the leaderships and even a
lot of the Civil Service gets changed uh
because they are looking for rewards for
their uh political
supporters uh but but the good side is
in our traditional leadership system
like in s Leon U as much as people
criticize it uh our people respect
chiy uh I'm never going to have to to
stand an election for the rest of my
life uh because our people trust that
the apartment chief uh is going to look
after their interest for the rest of
their lives so on the other hand I'm a
lot more accountable to my people and
I'm just giving myself as an example but
generally our traditional governance
system is a lot more stable otherwise
our country will have gone to Ports so
it's not all hopeless even though
there's a lot of churning at the
national level there's a lot of
stability also uh at the at local level
so it's good it would be good to try to
let leverage
that thank you Paramount Chief Farley Dr
tham
[Music]
okay
okay thank you Dr tham and our last
question for this round before we move
on before we move on to Q&A um would it
be fair to say that the lack of
universal Primary Health Care is in
itself a public health
emergency Dr
Don
yes the emergency systems are normally
built on the routine Health Care
Systems and most of our people seek
Health Care at a primary level
the primary
level uh normally is
weak because
uh one of the panelists earlier said our
governments and the systems are highly
centralized so you will realize that
most of the Improvement that is done is
done at the
central is not
if you take hospitals for example you'll
realize that our tertiary hospital if
you come to Liberia we have like two
tertiary hospitals the biggest one is in
Monrovia and what that brings to mind is
the focus in the budget that is given to
that is by far higher than what goes to
Primary Healthcare level and what that
brings to mind is our politicians will
think about themselves when they are ill
well they want want to go and so they
tend to invest in that
more at the expense of the Primary
Healthcare where the majority of the
people who voted for them do seek do
seek
healthare of course so when that when
the Primary Health Care level is not
strong enough when there's an
epidemic epidemic can
actually and overwhelmed the whole
country so the system need to be
considered as a whole and
not uh heavily weighed towards the elite
which is what is happening in most of
our countries thank you all right thank
you Dr Don um it is 102 and I want to
get to the Q&A section because we have
so much engagement from the audience um
so Paramount Chief Farley and Dr tham uh
could you please keep your response
brief
oh
yeah Primary Health Prim we we don't
have much of a primary health care uh to
start with uh because the components
that go into delivering Primary Health
Care uh we have one of those components
that we have nurses and and um you know
auxiliary health workers and even um
Community Health
officials um the they most people know
how to diagnose diseases but that's not
the real problem uh when you go there
you you inevitably they are going going
to inevitably ask for money uh that our
people don't have uh to buy medicines uh
and some of them actually ask for
consultations uh and and so most people
just don't get Primary Health Care even
though on paper uh you have all of these
Community Health uh offices built Health
Centers built uh but uh if you don't
have money which most of our rural
people don't have uh then then they
don't go there uh and so you have these
auxiliary units coming in and and it's
very dysfunctional so we don't have much
of a primary health care and yes uh that
is that is endemic that is an epidemic
because as I said yeah so so that that
that's the point to
make thank you parmount Chief Farley and
Dr
for
[Music]
and
okay thank you Dr tham um so now I'm
looking through the chat um and seeing
the questions that were sent to me from
the audience I see this first one here
is directed to Dr Don from your
experience as the former minister of
Health in Liberia how can International
funding be structured to not only
address Immediate Health crisis but also
contribute to the establishment of
enduring Healthcare systems are there
successful models or examples where inos
have played a pivotable role building
long-term Health Care infrastructure in
collaboration with local
entities okay thank you yes
um as a country the first thing is to
provide the directions for the country
and for those who want to help
you
so countries normally will develop
strategic plans and policies to provide
directions for the
country take for instance the health
sector policy
strategy on where you want to take the
health sector over a period of time
maybe five to 10
years now
implementing the policy and the strategy
is an another thing because many times
people develop policies strategies and
it's a document and it is sitting and
accumulate accumulating
dust
so working with
uh especially the decentralized level
where the implementation is actually
done normally we do an operational plan
which is
annual and in doing that operational
plan is to sit with the impl implenting
some of your Implement all your
implementing Partners within the county
and plan to align their resources
to the plan to be able to
implement now with my experience the
first thing is if the plan the national
plans and policies are done together it
provides the opportunity for donor
Partners to also be able to align their
resources to your priority so that's the
first thing now that those resources are
when it comes to the implementation
level those resources also need to align
properly to the operational plans that
you have in country and jointly you can
monitor together so in Liberia what we
did was to organize the health sector
Coordination Committee the
hscc which is where the health sector
policy decisions are
made it it is normally shared by the
minister of Health co-chair by the wh
rep all the donor partners are present
there and they tend to give inputs into
the strategy and the
policy so assign some of the technicians
during the development process and so
when they are planning their support
they plan along those
for us and that
work now there are other examples I did
mentioned earlier which systems will
continue to be weak we've had situations
where donor Partners work with us to
build financial management systems for
example currently I'm at the University
of Liberia at the College of Health
Sciences before I got there in
2019 the College of Health
Sciences had never managed
$500 budget everything was highly
centralized but this is an institution
where uh uh faculty members need to
write research grants they need to do
research they need to publish for their
own professional group the systems were
not there we were supported by with
donor funding by another uh us
institutions to build the office of
sponsored research to build a fin Office
of Financial Management we have a
monitoring and evaluation system in
place at the clees and uh we have a
human resource office we have a
communication office those systems were
not there and so when uh people want to
support you they don't see those systems
there it becomes risky to in put in
their money since we started uh in 2019
to present we managed over
$10 million or we are managing over $10
million at the moment is because the
systems are there of course the with the
system currently we are not only we are
not independent yet we are still working
with the partners and growing the system
until we can take on fully but most of
the work is done within our system and
they have high level supervision for it
and I think that is a very good model
because at the end of the day when the
international partner is now that that
system continues within the University
thank you thank you Dr Don um do you
think that NOS cause mismanagement of
resources as a whole or individuals with
them how can we ensure that resources go
directly to the community leaders to Aid
local support and governance um Dr tham
could you answer this
one okay I I
think
dist
me
[Music]
I thank you Dr and I see a question here
for Paramount Chief Farley how can donor
agencies and internet interational
organizations deal directly with local
leaders in managing situations like
these do government policies allow for
this uh not directly um if it
doesn't
um there's a huge dysfunction in a lot
of our postcolonial
countries uh where things are very
centralized um in the seity of
government
uh one way one walk around uh that you
can
develop I already mentioned this before
but I I'll say it again
um yes it's a good thing
to if you have credible
NOS I mean really credible NOS that are
really accountable and who they can deal
yes the central government will give
them General authority to operate in the
country but they can deal directly
uh with the with the traditional leaders
uh who are best trusted by the
communities uh to to deliver uh and so
the the model that I would suggest is is
um large International
organizations um as work with their uh
local Partners uh to deal directly uh
with the traditional
authorities um the government is already
getting although they always say it's
not enough the government is already
getting a lot of money from uh places
like the World Bank the African
Development Bank they use our our
Sovereign uh uh capacity uh to get to
get funding for uh a lot of lot of
things but a lot of that funding uh
doesn't filter down to the communities
uh the best way to get it to filter down
is to get a credible NGO and require
them
uh to deal directly with the with with
with the traditional leaders um who who
will um who will guide them a lot better
and and trust me the the communities
will benefit a lot more because those
traditional leaders are a lot more
accountable to their communities uh than
than our national governments of course
the national governments still play a
role in overall coordination of
registration of NOS but on a project by
project basis uh the best the most
efficient way of of impacting
communities is through their traditional
leaders and through Nos and through
their traditional
leaders all right thank you Paramount
Chief Farley I see Dr Don has two
fingers up so the floor is yours Dr
Don yes I just want to compliment what
he said it is possible to support uh
local governments
directly uh uh the same way I complained
about uh donor Partners Ping On not
being very transparent is the same thing
that happens with the government and the
central
government holding on and not letting go
to the local
governments ideally if you want that to
happen the local government system the
the the capacity need to be built the
same systems you have at the central
level needs to be in the local
government office and the different
agencies well built within their
local uh take for instance the county
within the county which most of you will
call District and then they report to
the local government office who is
headed by the
superintendent when you look at Liberia
you'll realize that some of the
services are decentralized to some
extent but one institution that will not
decentralize is finance ministry they
tend to hold on and don't let don't want
to let go and it's difficult to
understand why because the people who
work at the local government
level have went to the same schools you
went to you people graduated from the
same schools and you have the same
degrees
yes it happens in the health sector the
same way in the health sector you'll see
one program in immunization for example
they will forever be training training
of trainers they go to the local level
they train trainers you expect that the
people they train at trainers will scale
down the training but they the people at
the central will continue to go down to
the to the county and the district to
continue to do training so as a result
the trainers the tram can never have the
opportunity to tram but it takes the
government to make a serious decision to
decentralize decentralized it's easier
to decentralize with all the other
Ministries but they need to look at the
finance ministry and see how they can
decentralize finance ministry to support
the local government and all the other
things will follow that is very
difficult to do in our
setting Paramount Chief Farley you had
two figes just to butress um you know I
have I'm I'm a professional
engineer um over four decades so my Bend
is more to see the world as it is rather
than to and say how how will I get get
things done uh based on what how the
world is uh as Dr Dan said uh no
Ministry of Finance is going to uh um is
going to decentralize no matter what the
world bank or anybody else says
um I can give lots of examples I'm not
even going to bother with that um but so
the work around that is um work with
these NG the donor Partners can can fund
ngos directly but let them be reputable
D Nos and let the donor Partners uh get
feedback uh uh monitoring systems that
that ensures that they have in fact
dealt with the traditional leaders who
are trusted by their communities I think
that there's no way government can stop
that as long as the the NGS are working
in the country uh but to to say that
you're hoping because the World Bank has
been after our government forever to
decentralized and and they even have a
permanent decentralization Secretariat
and nothing get decentralized so instead
of following that just just go ahead and
walk around it uh walk through these
International NOS get them to be
credible and work directly with those
leaders nobody can stop
that thank you Paramount Chief Farley um
a next question from the audience says
looking into future outbreaks what can
technology digital Health tele medicine
or connectivity be used to improve the
handling of outbreaks um so Dr theam I
think we can start with
you
re
comp
cont
one question so we have only a five
minute warning uh how should external
actors whether they be bilateral or
International NOS navigate the degrees
of tension or separation between
traditional government and central
government typically there is for
Outsiders a need to go through central
government in order to get to the
traditional government um which has both
financial and programmatic implications
so for those of us who desire to work
more closely with local communities and
traditional leaders what advice would
you give for navigating this uh so
Paramount Chief Farley will start with
you
uh you obviously need to register once
you're registered as an NGO in the
country you uh your program itself you
can develop over um how you develop and
Implement your programs uh but obviously
you you have to register with some
Central agencies uh that's why it's a
good
workaround um you are not required to
implement all of your programs through
the central government in fact most most
NOS develop their own programs and deal
directly uh with local governments the
problem is getting the Dependable NOS
because there's also a lot of Mal
fistance within ngos a lot of them spend
most a good percent of of their funds
just having meetings and meetings and
meetings on end uh which their personnel
their own staff usually attends uh get a
lot of PMs and most of that is spend on
that overhead uh rather than on actually
programmatic things within the
communities
but I'm sure the best NGS uh will find a
way of of of delivering uh most of the
funding to the program itself uh and but
I can assure you just to build on
something Dr Tam had said uh right at
Independence there was a huge imbalance
between the level of education and
sophistication between those in central
government and those in in in
traditional institutions not anymore um
among Paramount Chiefs you have medical
doctors you have lawyers I'm a
professional engineer I'm a registered
professional engineer uh i' I've also
had uh done my masters in public
administration and business
administration and a lot of times we
actually you actually have a lot more uh
capable resources uh at the traditional
governance level uh than at at the
central government government level so
uh working through NGS get the NGS
registered but don't hesitate to to work
directly with with the traditional
leaders uh because you know we are
getting more and more uh
sophisticated thank you Paramount Chief
Farley and our last question will go to
Dr Don um as we only have one minute
left um what would you have done
differently to manage the crisis in
terms of managing resource mobilization
distribution channels to get the to get
it to who needs it the most and the
problems of trust and credibility
between citizens and and government
players uh so the last minute is yours
Dr
Don okay for me I will I will work in
building government
capacity I will work with them in
building the systems that supposed to be
built for them to be able to manage
their own resources plus my for plus
donor
resources uh an example is uh with the
some usid funding that is being managed
by the Ministry of Health the fixed
amount reimbursement agreements
uh this is an agreement between us Aid
and uh the Ministry of
Health uh the
min oh okay uh well unfortunately
because of the connectivity and it is uh
our final minute here we do have to end
so I just want to say you know thank you
to our panelists for a fantastic
discussion and thank you all for joining
us today we also want to thank our
sponsors the Yale Institute for Global
Health The Walker fund and the Council
on African studies at the McMillan
Center at Yale the session was recorded
and will be posted on the institutes for
Global Health conversation series
playlist on YouTube we look forward to
seeing you at the next event of the
global health convers ation series thank
you all and take
care thank you and thank you for
providing opportunity I hope we were
helpful it's been a
pleasure